how have you seen successful people
tackle problem solving and decision-
making I think successful people don't
Meander that much I I've seen people
they
they they go they make a decision
quickly I learned that from one of my
mentors this guy Jim Jordan he was
really good at like he wasn't indecisive
make a decision and it might not work
but it's a lot better I think that
frustrates people and I I I I may have
seen in videos that you had posted on
film courage that people get frustrated
sometimes on a film set the director
doesn't seem to know what they want you
know and I don't mean by saying like I
don't know but I mean that they're kind
of indecisive like they want to try
everything and people get annoyed at
that because it takes a really long time
and everything so sometimes you just
have
to go with God and make a decision and
hope for the best and I think uh I've
noticed that successful people do that
successful people go with their gut a
lot too I I I talked about like roblo
and Snoop Dogg have a lot in common you
wouldn't know that roblo is sober and
been sober for over 30 years and Snoop
Dogg is not sober I don't know if you're
aware of this he he likes to actually
partake in marijuana smoking believe it
or not so uh but they have a very
similar work ethic they grind constantly
and they're also always open to doing
stuff they're open to like new ideas
meeting people they're not closed-minded
they're very
open-minded and they're very
appreciative of their success they both
have an attitude like it could kind of
go away at at any moment and they're
great at fans to interacting with fans
Snoop was awesome with my kids Snoop was
on my son Cooper's YouTube channel and
was on his show twice soon was on my son
show not once he came on two different
times on my son's YouTube channel and it
would call him cou dog name's Cooper so
just great with my kids so nice Rob low
met my mom over the weekend my mom made
a beine to Rob low after the movie was
over and came up and started talking to
him and he just knew how to handle it
and said really nice things and they
just they just know they've been around
a long time A lot of times maybe if
someone has a b interaction with a
celebrity maybe sometimes they're the
one being rude like the way you approach
someone it's not
respectful but also sometimes it's
somebody that's maybe a little newer
that doesn't have that kind of know how
to just doesn't understand their
celebrity that much at this point Rob
blow Sno they know exactly who they are
so they know when someone meets them
it's a big deal and they know how to
play that Tom Cruz was that way I met I
worked with Tom Cruz um he Nar arated a
project on this guy Rick Hendrick who we
met for Days of
Thunder and uh we were waiting for him
to come into the room first of all I saw
this happen outside I went to go to the
bathroom I saw Tom Cruz is there like of
course he's here right when I have to go
to the bathroom and he's in like a dress
shirt and he takes off his shirt and he
says to his assistant can you grab me a
t-shirt out of my bag and he goes I
don't want to keep you waiting anymore
let's go so he just comes into the room
shirtless
now I saw I saw this unfold and it was
very normal like but no one in the
studio saw this they just saw Tom Cruz
come in without a shirt on and the the
audio engineer goes should we all take
our shirts
off so but Tom Cruz was a professional
like he not just a professional in his
narration but a professional in how he
interacted with everybody how respectful
he was like like he knew people's names
he he knew this was a big deal for the
people there to meet him but he he still
carried it with some humility and his
skin was Flawless looking like I'm
studying his skin and I'm like this is a
goodlooking guy and he was just uh yeah
he he had to pronounce this guy's name
uh It Was a Race Car Driver his name was
Jack sprag and for whatever reason Tom
Cruz couldn't pronounce this guy's name
name so like I remember he's reading
he's reading the vo and he's reading off
a teleprompter cuz he's dyslexic and
he's like like three time Truck Series
champion Jack
spook so he's like how is that I'm like
uh hey Tom actually that's uh it's not
spru it's sprag he's like okay got it no
problem so then he's like like three
time Truck Series champion Jack spr and
I'm like like is this guy screw with me
so I was like actually Tom Jack sprag
he's like sound it out for me
phonetically I'm like it's like Jack
spray and he's like got it do it from
the top so play he's like like three
time Truck Series champion Jack
spra I was like that's good enough good
good enough you know so and he was so he
was so nice and then so we finish up
we're talking about who this films about
Rick Hendrick and it was a very
emotional story this guy Rick
Hendrick's son and entire race team died
in a plane crash so Tom Cruz is doing a
favor and I'm talking about Rick
Hendrick I'm like he's such a nice guy
like he helped my my son when he was an
infant my son when he was an infant had
stomach issues he got him into a
hospital helped him out I mentioned that
to Tom Cruz he's like is your son is
your son all right and I like yeah he
think is there anything I can do and I'm
think thinking like what are you going
to do like Propel into the hospital or
something I don't know I'm like that' be
awesome if you want to help but he was
just he was just super nice and uh took
pictures and just
really uh just I just saw somebody who
totally understood his celebrity for
that little slice of two hours that I
got to spend with them sure yeah it's
really interesting when you when you're
there with someone who either has a
great reputation or a bad one and
sometimes they'll surprise you either
way I've seen people and I won't say
their names but who who were thought to
be kogy and they acted gracefully with
people and some of the people that came
up to them weren't that you know they
they were very demanding of photos or
whatever so sometimes yeah you just get
someone on a bad day that's what
happened with uh I was working with
Kevin cner he narrated this I went
through this stretch in NASCAR where I
worked with Paul Newman Kevin Cosner and
Tom Cruz in like three years they
narrated these projects so Kevin cner I
was told somebody gave me me this advice
they're like actors don't want to be
told how to read something you need to
give them the emotion so I was like okay
you know and Kevin Cosner's reading and
I give him some kind of Direction and I
was like can you can you maybe do it a
little more intensity Kevin and he's
like intensity okay sure so reads it I'm
like maybe even more intense and he's
like well you just read it for me and
I'm like he's like you just read it and
I'll just say it however you want me to
say it and then I remembered I'm like
what that guy said I'm like he's testing
me so I'm like I'm not going to do it so
I go no I don't want to tell you how to
read Kevin just give me the emotion and
then he's like come on you just just
tell me and I'm like no I don't want and
then he said like jokingly he's like
come on he called me the p word and and
and I realized everybody's full of [__]
no one knows what they're talking about
everybody's different he wanted to be
told exactly how to read it and uh he
was like the sweetest nicest this guy um
I've been really lucky like I've never
I'm actually trying to think I've I
don't think I've ever had a bad
experience with a celebrity I mean I
shouldn't say that I've had some but
they've been turned around I can tell
you this one a bad Snoop story that
turns good so we're on a shoot with
Snoop Dogg and he's he's miked and he
doesn't want us booming the scene
because it's like kind of a personal
thing he's going to talk about so the
audio guy goes hey snoop's chains are
all hitting his his mic you got to get
him to take off his chains and I'm like
really you want me I you can't do all
right so of course I've got to go up to
him and he's wearing like like 30 chains
gold chains and I go up and I tell him
hey it's hitting your
microphone and he's like pissed he's
like he's like MF this he's like you
don't tell a rapper to take his chains
off and this and I'm like uh once again
somebody much taller than me you I'm
like like looking up and I was like uh
Mr dog we're not going to hear the it's
not going to sound good and it's not
going to be usable so he said then you
wear the chains I was like I'll wear
them so he he takes off the chains puts
them around my neck and I'm like walking
around like Mr T with all these chains
on the whole shoot I'm wearing him so
did it does the scene it's great I go up
back up to him I go hey got your chains
and then he goes hey I just want to
apologize I I was rude sorry you
know didn't maybe say it exactly like
that but he was like thanks for pushing
me and I appreciate that and he goes
here you keep this chain and he gave me
one of his chains like a real weighty
gold chain diamonds on there and the
rest of the crew afterwards were eating
and they're like how much you think
that's worth you know I'm like I don't
know so I get home I went to a jewelry
store to get it appraised and this guy's
taking the chain and he's looking at it
with like one of those like monocle
things and he's like uh I would say it's
about 90 I'm like 90 grand and he's like
no $90 he's like he's like this is all
fake it's like cubic cironi
goldplated and like oh so I went to
Snoop I said uh hey I got your chain
appraise said it was only 90 bucks he
goes you don't get a gift appra raised
what's wrong with you he said that was a
gift he goes I don't wear real jewelry
when I'm out like I think we're at like
a bowling alley he goes of all my stuff
is like from King ice or something none
of that stuff's real and I said oh all
right fast forward to a couple years
later Snoop is telling me uh I'm going
through a divorce and I must have
mentioned it to one of his assistants or
something this person this woman Nani I
must have told told her about it so
Snoop calls me into a sprinter van and
he seems mad and the Sprinter van is
where he goes sometimes to partake in
his activities away from people so he
calls me in and he's like hey Nani told
me what you're going through really
sorry really he actually goes it breaks
my heart to hear that you're going
through that and maybe maybe because
it's coming from him at the time but I
just start like crying in front of him
like I just lost it and I'm thinking
great you know this is the guy who
didn't want to hug his kid on camera now
I'm crying so he actually like starts
comforting me and like puts his arm
around me and he like had a little tear
in his eye and uh I told this story to
him he doesn't seem to remember it but
he he was really like sweet to me and
then he said he actually said you know I
gave you that chain it was a lion and I
said no why he said well he said because
a lion protects their pride and you got
to be there for your kids no matter what
and you also you have the Heart of a
Lion so I remember that and then so I
got this tattoo this this is the chain
that uh that's beautiful Snoop had given
me the $90 chain so it held like a deep
deep meaning for me in that moment that
he would care enough to uh comfort me he
he offered to come to North Carolina to
do a deposition in court for me can you
imagine like one more WI please and like
Snoop Dog comes in I'm like you're never
coming to North Car why why are you
offering this that's never going to
happen he's like yeah but anyway um I
don't know where this all started
but